la meilleure vannes un meilleur vannes
qui est nommé pour la meilleure vente de
l'année
c'est parti pour le trophée de la
meilleure vannes
[Musique]
jean michel maire
pour connaissent isabelle depuis
longtemps gelé connue elle avait des
cheveux longs bouclés elle ressemblait
une princesse suédoise maintenant elle
est toujours belle
après lieu après la guerre cyril hanouna
j'espère que rien de grave mais voilà
donc à 5 heures du matin il a été arrêté
alors que des témoins disent avoir vu
son menton d 1h30
jean michel maire
cette question le prochain
pronostiqueurs officiel de la coupe du
monde de foot sera renom le chien non
voyants achille le chats sourds masi le
perroquet sans pattes on verdez le
pigeon simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean michel maire
[Musique]
c'est quoi votre père préférait donc la
préférée oui fillon un dessin n'est pas
qu'est ce qu'on met dans le fion pour le
faire ça se mange des sont fermés cyril
hanouna
donc j'ai failli connaître une très très
très bonne et puis tout à coup j'ai
pensé à tes défauts il y en a pour moi
qui est rédhibitoire tu pue du cul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le français fait de la meilleure vannes
qui a fait la meilleure vannes cette
année est bien au fait de la meilleure
ban c'est lui le gagnant
jean michel maire michel mr et lugano
vianney